هل سبق لك أن شعرت وكأنك عالق
في صندوق،
صندوق توقعات والديك،
صندوق المجتمع، الصندوق الذي تضع
نفسك فيه
جيدًا، أعتقد أن بعض الصناديق من المفترض
أن تكبر
عندما كنت أصغر سنًا، وأنجز ما يرضي شعب كونتي
ثم أنجزه  هل
قادني هذا حقًا إلى
طريق قلق للغاية حيث تبين أنني
شخص قلق للغاية وأريد القلق
ولكن في الأساس، يا عزيزتي،
شعرت أنه
لم يكن لدي وقت لنفسي أبدًا، لقد
استنزفت طاقتي حقًا
وانتهى بي الأمر بتركيز كل انتباهي عليه
أشخاص آخرين، لذلك لم أكن أعرف أبدًا ما
أريد أن أفعله وما أريد أن أكونه،
ولم يكن لدي الوقت للتفكير في أي من
هذه الأشياء على أي حال، لذلك عندما كنت أعود إلى
المنزل عندما كنت أصغر سنًا، اعتدت
الجلوس وكنت أفعل ذلك  أجلس في غرفتي وكنت
أكتب، كنت أكتب الشعر،
كنت أرسم وكنت أغني، لذلك عندما
كنت أصغر سنا اكتشفت أنني أستطيع
الغناء وشاركت في جميع المسرحيات
الموسيقية المدرسية التي يمكن أن تفكر فيها
حتى  كان عمري 11 عامًا. عندما انتقلت إلى
المدرسة،
فقدت كل شيء تمامًا، وأصبت
برهاب المسرح، وخشيت كل ما
يمكن أن يخطر ببالك، وقد فقدت
نفسي في هذه العملية،
لذا توقفت عن الغناء، وتوقفت عن الكتابة،
واحتفظت بالرسم في  الحد الأدنى
ولكن عندما بدأت أحب
الحياة، تعلم أنني عدت إليها للتو ولكن
لم
أخبر شخصًا ما أنني أعرف كيفية الغناء إلا عندما بلغت 16 عامًا
ونشرت قصتي الأولى ولكن لا أحد
يحب التركيز حقًا أو لا أحد حقًا
كنت أهتم ولم أكن كذلك، وعندما كنت في
الصف الثاني عشر أوصاني أحدهم
بالغناء في حفل تخرجي وكان كل ما كنت
أفكر فيه على ما يرام في ذهني،
سأصعد على المسرح وسأغني، وسيكون هذا هو
هدفي  لم أكن أعلم
أنها لم تكن لحظتي التي كنت أبحث فيها عن
التحقق من الصحة في المكان الخطأ أو هكذا
اعتقدت عندما ذهبت إلى هناك
لم أشعر بأي شيء على الإطلاق، لم أشعر أنني
بحاجة إلى التحقق من صحة أي شخص، لم أشعر
أنني كذلك  كنت أبحث عن التحقق من صحة
الأشخاص الآخرين، كنت أبحث عن ذلك في
نفسي، كنت فخورًا لأنني اتخذت الخطوة
للأمام وقلت نعم، وأنني
تمكنت من الغناء في حفل تخرجي وتوقف الأمر عند هذا الحد،
ولم أفكر في الأمر لفترة
أطول  وأنت تعلم أن
الشعور بأن الأشخاص من حولك لا
يدعمونك حقًا ليس أفضل طريقة
تعرفها للمضي قدمًا في الأشياء
التي تريد القيام بها، كما أحب
الانتقال إلى الجامعة، لقد غيرت
الأشخاص من حولي في رحلتي الثانية  في العام التالي، كنت
محاطًا بحشد سيء حقًا
وتحول كل شيء إلى رماد عندما بدأ
الحجر الصحي، ولكن كان ذلك بداية
كل شيء، كل شيء جيد بالنسبة لي، على
الأقل
بدأت في إعادة الاكتشاف حقًا
وفي فبراير 2021 قمت بنشر الفيديو الحقيقي الخاص بي،
أول فيديو حقيقي على التكنولوجيا.  تحدث
وعلى Instagram وفي ذلك الوقت كنت قد
وصلت للتو إلى 2000 متابع واعتقدت أن
هذا أمر جنوني، لذا
واصلت وواحدًا تلو الآخر بدأت في
النشر أكثر فأكثر
وبدأ الناس في الابتعاد عن
أنفسهم، شعرت وكأنني محتوى
منشئ المحتوى ليس رائعًا، وليس عصريًا، لذا فقد
فقدت الكثير من الأشخاص خلال طريقي
للقيام بهذا الشيء غير التقليدي الذي
اعتقد الجميع أنه من المحرمات للغاية،
ووجدت أن الأشخاص بدأوا في إلغاء
متابعتي، وقام بعض الأشخاص بحظري، مما
حطم علاقتي حقًا  احترام الذات لكنني
قررت أنني ما زلت بحاجة إلى القيام بما
أردت القيام به خلال هذه المرحلة من
حياتي أثناء الحجر الصحي، بدأت
بمشاهدة مقاطع فيديو garyvee وكان Gary Vee
مثلي الأعلى إذا كنت لا تعرفه فهو رجل
أعمال ورائد
أعمال  المدرب الذي
يخبرك أساسًا أنك تفعل ما تريد
وتسعى وراء ما تؤمن به لأنك إذا
لم تفعل ذلك فسوف تقضي بقية
حياتك نادمًا على ذلك إذا بقيت في
والديك، ظل إذا بقيت في
دائرة تعرفها  لا يُظهر
أفضل ما لديك، وسوف تندم على
ذلك لبقية حياتك، لذلك
شاهدت مقاطع الفيديو تلك واستمرت
وتابعت وبدأت في نشر المزيد من
مقاطع الفيديو الغنائية حول كتابة الأغاني الخاصة بي
وخطوة بخطوة  الخطوة وجدت
أنه كان صحيحًا أنني أستطيع أن أفعل ما أردت أن
أفعله طوال هذا الوقت ولذلك سلكت
طريقين غير تقليديين قررت أنني
أريد أن أصبح مغنية ثم
قررت أنني أريد أيضًا أن أقوم
بإنشاء المحتوى منذ أن أحببت  التواجد أمام الكاميرا
الآن كان هناك سبب لذلك، تذكر
كيف أخبرتك أنني كنت من
الأشخاص الذين يسعدون بشدة بإرضاء الناس أثناء نشأتي، أشعر أن
ذلك يترجم تلقائيًا إلى ذهني
إلى مثل أريد أن يتم سماعي، أريد أن
يتم رؤيتي، أريد أن أكون على  الشاشة
واعتقدت أن هذا كان حلم كل طفل،
حلم كل طفل هو أن يكون مشهورًا وأن
يريد أن يكون أمام الكاميرا وأن يعيش
أسلوب حياة ساحر ولكن كما اتضح،
لم يكن حلم كل طفل
والسبب في أنه كان حلمي هو أنني  لا يبدو أنني
لم أشعر بأنني سمعت ولم أشعر بأنني أرى،
لذا عد
إلى الوقت الذي كنت فيه في
الحجر الصحي مرة أخرى، كنت أستمع إلى
أغاني كايروكي دينيًا إذا كنت لا
تعرف غاريفي، فأنا متأكد من أنك تعرف كايروكي
لذلك كانت هناك الأغنية التي سأغنيها
وبدأت الغناء في حديثي عن التكنولوجيا
وكما كان الناس يأتون إلي
لاحقًا في الشارع ويقولون لي أوه
أنت الفتاة التي تغني [
موسيقى]
أشعر بها
[موسيقى]
و  لقد كانت أغنيتي المفضلة لذلك
بدأت للتو في القيام بالأشياء الخاصة بي
وتحسنت حقًا وفي ذهني
تلك الخطوة التي أردت المضي قدمًا بها،
وعلى الرغم من أن الأمر لم يكن
بهذه السهولة حقًا، فقد
تركت توقعات الجميع مني تذهب
و  لقد خرجت من الصندوق الذي
وضعته لنفسي عن طريق الخطأ لأنه عندما
يراك الناس بطريقة معينة
تبدأ تلقائيًا في رؤية نفسك بهذه
الطريقة وعندما ينظر إليك الأشخاص الخمسة الأساسيون
من حولك بطريقة معينة
ويخبرونك أن أحلامك كبيرة جدًا و
واقعك مثير للسخرية تمامًا،
تبدأ في تصديق ذلك، ولذلك تركت الأمر يمضي
وتركتهم يرحلون، ووجدت الأشخاص
الذين كنت سأضعهم في دائرتي الداخلية من
حولي
وقادوني إلى الأمام، لذا منذ بضعة أشهر
في يونيو/حزيران كنت  في الفصل الدراسي الأخير لي في
الجامعة، وكان لدي وظيفة تسويق في
هذه الوكالة وكرهتها تمامًا وكان هناك
صوت في رأسي
يقول لي افعل ذلك، افعل ما يفعلونه،
يمكنك القيام بذلك بشكل أفضل لأنهم أكبر سنًا ولكن
يمكنك ذلك  أفعل ذلك بشكل أفضل
وكافحت من أجل البقاء في ذلك المكان
وكافحت من أجل الشعور بالاحتواء كما
اعتدت أن أشعر بالاحتواء من قبل، لذلك تركت
وظيفتي وفي تلك الليلة كنت في
التجمع جيدًا،
كانت آنا تحتفظ بحساباتك على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
هل تسمح لي و  سأفعل ذلك
مجانًا، أليكس ليو
في تلك الليلة، وكالة رائعة، استقلت من
وظيفتي وبدأت في القيام بالأشياء الخاصة بي،
إنه أمر محظور للغاية بالنسبة لوالديك
والأشخاص من حولك بشكل عام يعتقدون
أن ترك الجامعة والحصول على دوام من
التاسعة إلى الخامسة  الوظيفة تشبه إلى حد كبير أن هذا هو
الشيء الطبيعي الذي يجب القيام به وهو أمر
بالغ الأهمية لسيرتك الذاتية
ومحفظتك هل ستكون ناجحة في
المستقبل ولكني لم أصدق أنه
لم يكن هناك قوس قزح وفراشات
وأقحوانات
على الإطلاق  العمل ليلاً ونهارًا
لم يكن الأمر أسهل، دعني
أقول ذلك ولكنني قررت أن أفعل ذلك وسأكون
ممتنًا إلى الأبد لهذا
القرار الذي جاء من غاريفي لذلك
أعتقد أنني يجب أن أشكره
ولكن نعم
في النهاية  في ذلك اليوم
عرفت للتو أن القيام بوظيفة من الساعة التاسعة إلى الخامسة
والقيام بكل هذه الأشياء التي
وضعها المجتمع أمامي وأخبرني أنني كنت
سأكون
نسخة غير سعيدة للغاية وباهتة من نفسي
وأنا  أنا سعيد دائمًا لأنني لم
أتمكن من مقابلتها أبدًا ولكن هذه هي
الطرق التي هربت بها من
هاواي التقليدية، ما هي طرقك شكرًا لك
[تصفيق]